and finally new rule now that many
Republicans now that many Republicans
have come forward in the last week to
finally admit that okay you were right
sarah palin is a crazy person they have
to ask themselves what else might I have
been completely wrong about all these
years now in case you missed it palin
made a speech in iowa a couple of weeks
ago that cryptologists are still working
on which i have been holding off on
discussing on the outside chance it
might be brilliant in some other
language let's look at a few moments
shall we to see for ourselves what
prompted conservatives to finally throw
sarah palin under the bus he who was the
one now with tea time on the mind okay
this is to forego a conclusion right
it's to scare us off and convince us
that that a pantsuit can crush Patriots
it's kind of Orwellian observing how
that works that rule of Saul Alinsky's
no doubt boy that really brings me back
to the 80s when you'd get a chick back
to your apartment to do coke and she do
too much and start rambling and you'd
think boy I make a huge mistake here
now to be fair Democrats make huge
mistakes - taking pictures of your dick
comes to mind well let's face it this
isn't a 50-50 thing Democrats can be
fuzzy thinkers but Republicans will look
you right in the eye and tell you the
two plus two equals Jesus but not
anymore with Sarah Palin the pundits who
always defended her have now officially
had enough It was as if the scales fell
from their eyes and they were finally
able to admit the emperor has no clues
they called her speech incoherent a
farce unseemly words that might have
truly stung Sarah if she knew what they
meant for example Matt Lewis who
previously had loved Palin so much he
wrote an adoring book about her penned a
column titled you betcha I was wrong
about Sarah Palin and said quote maybe
her early critics saw some fundamental
character flaw that escaped me you think
I'm not saying Matt sticks with losers
for a long time but he wrote this on
MySpace but
but he's hardly alone Bill O'Reilly
compared it to a reality show Sean
Hannity asked did the teleprompter go
down the Washington Examiner questioned
whether she should be included in future
Republican events and Bill Cosby said I
wouldn't drug her with your drink I made
that last but hey we're not here to
gloat oh no we're just here to say
didn't that feel good to finally purge
yourself of something that wasn't
sitting well in your gut it's like when
you're sick and you make yourself throw
up you feel better afterwards
I only have one question for Republicans
what took you so long
the rest of us have been watching this
dog eat grass for seven years
but now that you know that you can do
this what about writing a column called
you betcha I was wrong about climate
change I feel good
Germany get 74% of its electricity from
renewables and they don't live in the
future they're a real country turn left
at Austria it's right there look I'm up
in a history book they're always up to
something
or what about giving up on the idea of
sending 12 million Mexicans back to
Mexico
there aren't enough trains ask Germany
and as long as we're in a rethinking
mood you might know yo it might be a
good one
Middle East invasions Iraq Afghanistan
Syria now Iran all these places you want
to send heroic snipers turns out they
don't like it they're just not that into
being sniped and what about the great
granddaddy of zombie lies trickle-down
economics can't we throw that one under
the bus too it's never worked and it nil
never will work for a good reason
because it's like having three dogs and
giving a weiner to one of them and
thinking he'll share it with the others